we're kicking it off by looking back at
this day
in pop culture history
on this day in 2015 the longest running
host in late night
tv history said his goodbyes
with the final episode of the late show
with david letterman the finale featured
four living presidents
seinfeld chris rock barbara walters bill
murray
and a send-off from dave's most beloved
band the foo
fighter this is dave's 6 000th
wow and 28 episode of fitting farewell
after 33 incredible years of interviews
endless self-deprecation
and dave's beautiful wonderful spirit
i'm glad that he graced the presence of
this studio
by showing up for an old friend me
yeah on your birthday i'll never forget
that like what it was like to see him in
in here i mean such a legend and you
guys have your own history i mean you
doing that show is iconic
i did not know what i was doing on that
birthday show of his i was that was
spontaneity the definition of
spontaneity i was just playing around
with dave
yeah and you two together are just
absolute magic
well congrats to dave and next we got a
real spicy story for you drew you're
gonna love this
mashable reports the newest way to get
flirty over your cell phone
is not a text no it's the sexy little
voice memo
people are branching out from the not
safe for work picks with some not safe
for work clips
they talking dirty if you want to get
into this with your special person
here's how you do it first you get
consent of course
and then you record a little message you
know where the little microphone is on
the text
yeah it's like it's not the microphone
you speak in to do
like voice memos it's the little
microphone within the text bubble itself
and this is really confusing because you
have to hold it down the whole time and
then you like
swipe up in an arrow send it but the
point is rather than like hey baby hubba
hubba
people are like you know it works not
with my voice
but i i see how this could sort of be
very very
sexy all right well next
um we have a real game changer in
today's green news
i love green nose ross did you know that
one
third of all food goes to waste one
third
no i didn't is that true it is
depressingly true
wow once it hits the landfill all that
food is responsible for eight percent of
all greenhouse gas emissions
worldwide well there is really
interesting news i'm very excited about
this story
there's a brand new app that's tackling
this
the good news network reports that too
good to go
lets you buy leftovers from your
favorite restaurants before they get
thrown out
the app is already in 15 countries
and spreading throughout the us it shows
which restaurants near you
have leftovers and you can buy them at a
deep discount
and then you show up at your designated
pickup time
with your reusable bag and collect your
food
you are truly saving whatever is a
surplus
and you get a surprise every time i mean
i am so moved by this story this is this
is all you drew because it's like
one it's like um it's
the consumer doing one thing to make
such a huge difference right and this
time the consumer's winning because
they're getting a good deal i mean these
prices are cut like
big time down there's major discounts
food is not getting wasted
you know we can do these systems
differently
and i think this app has actually made
it possible because these are kind of
lofty goals and aspirations at least
i talk about and when i see a company
actually putting it into practice
figuring it out and making a difference
in business and people's lives
thank you i am so excited about this
yeah me too and i can't wait to see all
the restaurants who are going to
participate
chili's i'm talking to you if you got
any more that leftover queso dip i'm on
my way
thank you so much we're going to keep
you posted about this app because i
think it's incredibly pioneering and i'm
really supportive
watch it take off all right finally
twitter just added a brand new
innovative feature of their own bbc news
reports
they're launching something called a tip
jar so you can tip people
for their tweets yeah tips they're just
starting to roll out now but pretty soon
you're going to see that tip jar icon
next to a user's name
and you can click on it to tip them on
venmo cash app or paypal
this is odd it's interesting um
i think of things like gofundmes um
which seems obviously much more about
the person
reaching out and saying i need this
this is sort of the other side of the
coin this is like
i like what you did i'd like to
compensate in some way or
give you a little extra is that sort of
the notion i guess
i want to see how this is going to be
used i mean it's just going to be like
celebrities begging for money
i'm not interested but if it's going to
be like if somebody sees someone do
something incredible
and retweets it and says hey everyone
support this person who was so
charitable or so kind or is
in need then i can get behind that i
just have to see the intent
i i agree it has to be used in the right
way um well
i'm i'm excited i think we've learned
about a lot of new apps that could make
a big difference
you